meine Damen und Herren es ist an der
Zeit dass ich in minecraft WE in eine
Höhle
gehe zum allerersten Mal zuvor würde ich
allerdings sagen dass wir den lavaeimer
erstmal hier kurz platzieren sod dass
ich mir einen Wassereimer mitnehmen kann
sodass ich halt wenn ich in der Höhle
bin irgendwann wieder nach oben
schwimmen kann und ist unsere
weizenfarmch dier abstoßen ich ma mir
noch mal eben kurz eine komplette
eisenausrüstung W gefragt hat und zieh
mir dann auch schon direkt meine
eisenhose und Eisen hannisch an S dass
wir ausgerüstet sind für die
Höhle diger ich hasse dieses Boot fahren
ich Snack mir noch mal kurz hier ein
gebratenen Lachs rein den wir aus der
Kiste bekommen haben wähle direkt mein
Eisenschwert aus und los
[Musik]
geht oh oh mein Gott Z war ein Huhn los
geht's rein in die
[Musik]
Höhle oh es geht direkt los
au oh mein
Gott
wow SP warum Set was warum was ist los
wo bist
du alter nimm das Schwert nim das
Schwert warum ne ich wieder die
Spitzhacke dier das ist nicht
W ich habe meinen allerersten Kampf
verloren
gegen ein miniombie obwohl ich eine
halbe eisenrüstung anhatte ich weiß
ehrlich gesagt nicht wie das was werden
soll ne au zumindest sind die ganzen
Items noch hier der kleine Mini Zombie
ist weg und ist gerade schon wieder
dunkel wird würde ich sagen setze ich
mein Bett direkt hier hin geh eine Runde
schlafen und wir gehen das Ganze am
neuen morgen ruhig und gekonnt
an weiterer Tag von den 100 Tagen haben
wir geschafft ich gehe jetzt mit einem
Plan an die Sache ich nehme mein Wasser
nehme mein Schwert bin ausgerüstet und
wir schauen jetzt erstmal nach
[Musik]
Erzen perfekt gar nichts von daher würde
ich
sagen WOW oh mein
Gott er hat mich gesehen
aus nichts passiert wir müssen einfach
auf Abstand bleiben ich sehe Eisen und
ich sehe ein Skelett was uns aber nicht
sieht und daher gehen wir mal ganz
sneaky hier
rüber und gönen uns den Eisenblock war
leider nur einer das da vorne brauchen
wir nicht Kupfer den sin habe ich noch
nie verstanden da vorne ist noch Eisen
das
wow nicht mit
mir
tschüss würd ich mich gerne abschießen
geht aber leider
nicht oh mein Gott oh wow ich komme mit
Virtual Reality immer noch nicht klar
Kohle Kohle Kohle Kohle Kohle Kohle
[Musik]
Idee s noch einer ich habe keine Ahnung
von Minecraft schöner helligter Tag da
oben es könnte nicht besser
[Musik]
la ich wollte gerade den Satz noch mal
anfangen Acher schei
drauf nimm das an
oh ich habe abgebaut Nummer 2 moin
Meister und dann laufen wir jetzt mal
einfach wieder hier vorne lang zack hier
runter hier
[Musik]
lang wie soll ich denn
jetztunter kannst du mir nicht me den T
[Musik]
reinen da vorne ist alles voll mit
Monstern und da sind meine Sachen und
wir könnten nach da vorne
abhauen soll ich
[Musik]
ja lauf lauf lauf ich weiß ja noch immer
nicht wie man
okay das überlebe ich zack zack zack
okay ich bleib jetzt erstmal hier da ist
eine Fledermaus Hier wird keiner
hinkommen glaube
ich hier wird niemand hinkommen hoffe
ich ich höre
Monster ich bau mir ein
Dach perfekt Set halt eine
[Musik]
Fackel
wir haben eine kleine Base so also
erstmal ganz kurz organisieren was haben
wir alles V ach du
scheiße meine Hose ist weg ah da ist er
das war das wichtigste die war von
Balenciaga 10 Sekunden
später ich weiß nie ob ich sneake oder
nicht oh
Kohle ich bin einfach so arm diger dass
ich jetzt gerade erstmal oh mein Gott
ach du scheiße ach mann jetzt ist auch
noch Nacht und daher mache ich mir
direkt auch mal eben kurz ein zweites
Bett ich habe eins hinten in der Höhle
und dann eins auf jeden Fall hier damit
ich jetzt zumindest erstmal die Nacht
überspringen kann weil ich no joke kein
Bock habe dass ich gleich darüber fahre
und dann bevor ich in der Höle drin
schon wieder getötet
werd so wir haben Tag also ich habe mir
jetzt gerade ein bisschen Holz hier
gemacht werde mir jetzt noch mal ein
bisschen Steine nehmen ich habe nicht
mal mehr Steine ey das ist doch nicht
wahr wie am Arsch ich bin hier kommt das
dritte Boot Freunde
[Musik]
moin und Leute Trix hier
das kannst du dir alles nicht mehr
ausdenken ich bin schlau wir haben
basically alle unsere Sachen wieder am
Start Freunde befinden uns immer noch in
der Höhle
und sind ehrlich gesagt schon ziemlich
tief
drin ich nehme mal kurz hier dies Gold
mit
[Musik]
und dann bin ich ganz ehrlich weiß ich
auch gar nicht so genau wo wir hingehen
sollen und überall kommt irgendwie Lava
wir bräuchten halt echt mal ein
wassereimal das wäre ganz geil aber
sonst halte ich mich jetzt erstmal hier
mit Bruchsteinen über
[Musik]
Wasser das ist wie ein Horrorspiel für
ach guck mal Eisen das ist eine richtige
eisenhöhle da pass ich
ja ich hasse spinn oh mein
Gott ich la weg ich kann nicht sprinten
ich habe drei Herzen und ich kann nicht
sprinten was soll ich machen sind noch
hinter
mir
Redstone wow die schwimmt hier
runter ich kann nicht mer
hochbauen
ey ich brauche meine Lieben n
Zombie scheiß drauf diger das sind
Probleme von zukunftslukas